the movie opens with an elderly and
intoxicated man named fluger digging up
a grave that has some religious markings
he seems to be performing a ritual of
some sorts after a while fluger manages
to retrieve a person's skull from the
grave which suddenly releases white
smoke and knocks him back as he wakes
from the ground fluger laughs as if his
mission is completed the scene then
shifts to a teenager named Kelly who is
shopping at a convenience store here we
get to know that Kelly has a habit of
chewing papers and due to this his
classmates call him trash can to bully
him while he is going through the items
he meets his childhood friend and Crush
Dominique but hesitates to talk to her
outside the store Kelly is confronted by
his school bullies Nelson Tony Reed and
Brad they make fun of him for eating
strange things like paper and styrofoam
just as they're bothering him Dominique
steps in and urges them to stop this
angers the bullies even more and they
push Kelly's face into a trash bin
fortunately the store owner intervenes
stopping the the bullies and chasing
them away after this Dominique offers
Kelly a ride to the school however her
friend Sarah who owns the car refuses to
let him in mentioning that she does not
want her car to be dirty but from the
sounds of things he'd just eat the
garbage in the back and make it clean in
the next scene Kelly reaches school only
to find that the bullies had recorded
the store incident and spread it online
as he walks through the hallway all of
the students make fun of him after
school Kelly returns home and his mother
Bernice inquires about his day our boy
does not mention the bullying and simply
replies that Dominique talked to him for
the first time hearing this Bernice
becomes happy and suggests that he asked
Dominico on a date meanwhile an
indigenous man named Red Elk comes
across the grave which fluger destroyed
earlier and offers prayers it is then
revealed that his secret power was
hidden in the grave and it has been
stolen Red Elk is very sad to learn this
because it was his responsibility to
take care of it the following morning
Kelly Falls ill from consuming a lot of
paper and styrofoam Bernice immediately
summons the family doctor is he sick doc
no he's just an idiot the doctor
suggests that he see a psychologist for
Kelly's eating disorder he also hints
that Kelly might be acting abnormally as
there are no males in the house but in
reality the doctor has a crush on
Bernice and he simply wants to get in
bed with her the same day fluger is
shown in town claiming to have the power
to heal people he demonstrates it by
relieving an old woman's joint pain
coincidentally Bernice is also there and
she gets impressed by his skills
believing that he might help Kelly she
invites him to her house while Bernice
steps away to get her car Red Elk
confronts fluger and informs him that
the powers are not meant for him he also
offers to help him get rid of his
healing powers however fluger declines
and a scuffle ensues where Red Elk ends
up injuring himself this is due to the
powers fluger received from the grave
which protects their possessor Red Elk
then warns fluger about the consequences
of the power but the latter dismisses
him and walks away after a while fluger
reaches Bernice's house and when he
tries to heal Kelly he feels a strange
pain and quickly pulls his hand away he
then excuses himself to the bathroom and
consumes a special drug before
attempting again unfortunately when he
tries again he accidentally Burns
Kelly's chest with his cigarette and
collapses to the floor dying on the spot
strangely as fluger dies Kelly's
condition improves and he stands up
feeling quite energetic soon the police
arrive at the scene and take away
fluger's body they conclude that the Old
Man simply died of a cardiac arrest next
Kelly notices that the burn on his chest
is miraculously healed and he has gone
through some physical changes as well it
becomes clear that fluger's healing
powers have been transferred to Kelly
the next day Kelly accidentally cuts his
finger while repairing his bike but
something amazing occurs the wound heals
itself and instantly disappears he tries
to tell his mom about it but she doesn't
believe him his dick has also grown
three sizes but he can't go telling Mom
about that now can he on his way to
school he meets Dominique and Sarah who
are astonished to see him looking so
much healthier after they leave Nelson's
brother Reed approaches Kelly and starts
hitting him for no reason surprisingly
as he punches Kelly in the stomach Reed
feels the pain while our boy remains
unharmed Reed even tries to hurt Kelly
with a wooden block but it doesn't work
and he ends up injuring himself
understanding that he can't defeat this
new version of Kelly Reed then runs away
with bruises on his face later that
evening Gus Reed's father and the
football coach at school visits Kelly's
house to find out what happened to his
son Kelly explains that Reed came to hit
him but God hurt himself Gus of course
does not believe in this and argues with
Bernice however Bernice urges Gus to
leave and closes the door in his face
eventually after he leaves Kelly
confides in his mom about his ability to
transfer pain ensuring that no one can
hurt them again he proves this by
withstanding the heat of a cigarette
lighter which does no harm to his palm
the following day in class Kelly's
imagination runs wild as he finds
Dominique's hair band and envisions
himself and her getting intimate he also
begins thinking of Sarah in a threesome
encounter soon he'll find out if he
transfer the pain of rejection
surprisingly the sensations start
affecting Dominique and Sarah in real
life both of the girls feel strange
Sensations in their bodies leading to
unexpected reactions Sarah even screams
into light in the classroom later at a
night party Nelson behaves
inappropriately by picking up Dominique
without her consent this angers Kelly so
he confronts Nelson and urges him to put
Dominique down but as the boys are about
to clash Gus steps in and separates them
he then confronts Kelly and mentions
that one day he will surely find out the
power he possesses and to destroy it
after the party is over while everyone
is on their way home Brad and his
friends come across Kelly who is riding
his bike because of the previous
incident they are still angry and
attempt to push him off the road with
their car unfortunately Brad loses
control and hits Kelly with the car
running it over him the impact seems
severe but When the Smoke Clears it
turns out that Brad's skull has been
crushed leading to his death while Kelly
is unharmed soon a crowd gathers and
Kelly secretly explains the situation to
Dominique including his extraordinary
ability Nelson and his friends lie to
the police claiming that Brad swerved to
protect Kelly because he was cycling in
the middle of the road however a
preliminary investigation by the police
officer Adler clears Kelly of any
wrongdoing on the other hand Red Elk
learns about fluger's demise and visits
his grave analyzing the soil he
concludes that fluger lost his power
before dying upon hearing about Kelly's
survival after being hit by a car Red
Elk pays him a visit at his workplace he
confronts Kelly about the powers and
after a bit of hesitation the latter
confesses to being treated by fluger the
next day Kelly and Dominique are having
lunch at a cafe and talking about movies
they're ignoring the fact that Kelly
crushed Brad's skull in reality
Dominique also likes Kelly and wishes
that he would ask her for a movie night
to her good luck he does just that and
the two agree to watch a movie soon at
the same time Nelson and his friends are
upset seeing Kelly move forward with his
life so easily they decide to avenge
Brad's death teach him a lesson how can
they teach a lesson if they never learn
one themselves later at night after
learning about Kelly and Bernice's
schedule Nelson and his boys wait for
Bernice to leave for her night shift
however she falls ill and decides to
skip her shift seeing his mother on well
Kelly asks her to rest and heads to town
to buy medicine for her noticing a car
driving away Nelson and the group
mistake Kelly for Bernice and decide to
scare him they attached Kelly's trailer
house to their truck and pull it with
full power with Bernice still inside
they accidentally dragged the trailer
away making her fall from the couch the
chain doesn't detach properly so the
group leaves it in the truck after
wrecking the trailer because of this a
pipe of gas bursts in the kitchen and
fills the house shocked Bernice tries to
exit but stumbles upon a lamp and falls
to the floor unfortunately the lamp
catches fire and the gas ignites causing
a huge explosion after a while Kelly
arrives at the scene and rushes into the
trailer to save his mother tragically
he's too late as Bernice has already
passed away the traumatic experience
deep deeply affects Kelly and he Mourns
his mother's death Inside the Fire after
a while officer Adler spots burn marks
on Kelly's Body and admits him to the
hospital in the next scene Red Elk
approaches Adler at the hospital and
informs him about Kelly's unique power
He suggests discussing the matter with
Kelly but Adler deems it inappropriate
to delve into ancient folk tales during
such a challenging period in Kelly's
life understanding the situation Red Elk
tells Adler to reach out when the time
is right the following day after
miraculously healing his burn marks
Kelly goes straight to his mother's
funeral where he is supported by
Dominique she assures him that crying
doesn't make him weak and that his
mother will always be proud of him Kelly
then Reveals His plan to leave town
which disappoints Dominique and after
sharing a heartfelt kiss she leaves
after that Kelly visits fluger's grave
in the same cemetery and begins eating a
wild weed growing on it he hopes that it
can take his powers away however as soon
as he choose them he feels sick and
begins vomiting Sarah who happens to be
nearby Witnesses everything from from a
distance oh he's a recovering vegan
later officer Adler drives Kelly to
Social Services and discusses his
mother's accident with him learning that
the trailer fell before the gas
explosion Kelly becomes convinced that
it was no accident and someone knowingly
pulled it to break the support at the
same time Nelson and his boys are
driving in their truck showing No
Remorse for their actions they are
heading to the Riverbend to unwind
probably with beef jerky and hand jobs
on the way they encounter Adler driving
Kelly out of town and taunt him when our
boy notices the truck he immediately
realizes that they are the ones who are
responsible for his mother's death hence
without wasting any time he jumps out of
the moving car and stealthily pursues
them to the Riverbend later while Tucker
swims and the others playfully throw
stones at him Kelly slowly grabs
Tucker's shirt and uses it to strangle
himself this leads to Tucker struggling
to breathe and stay afloat ultimately he
drowns in the river as Nelson and the
others look on in horror they
immediately rush to help him but it is
too late the bully has done Kelly then
arrogantly reveals himself as being
responsible for Tucker's death he
attempts to grab Nelson's shirt but just
then officer Adler arrives at the scene
Kelly quickly runs away to avoid any
trouble and the bullies try their best
to explain what happened however Adler
finds the story hard to believe and he
instead starts suspecting them of their
friend's murder that night Kelly meets
Dominique and admits his plan to avenge
his mother's death however she suggests
that getting Nelson and the others to
confess is better than resorting to
violence Kelly also agrees to her words
even though it's too late he already
killed one of them and they share a
close moment together the next day Kelly
purposely provokes one of the bullies
Tony in chemistry class hoping to make
him confess to Bernice's murder at first
the bully controls himself but when
Kelly makes fun of his girlfriend Sarah
he loses his cool and throws acid at
Kelly unfortunately because of his
powers Tony ends up burning himself and
dies on the spot these bullies are so
dumb it hurts me witnessing all of it
Dominique gets enraged at Kelly
compelling him to leave at night a
grieving Sarah meets Nelson and they
conspire to avenge Tony's death here she
informs him about a Vine from the
cemetery that made Kelly vomit together
they then head to the graveyard to
retrieve it and use it as a weapon
against Kelly the next day Gus takes his
sons to football practice where Adler
notices the chain used by the bullies on
Gus's truck he questions Nelson and read
about it but they deny having any
information just then Kelly arrives at
the practice ground with an electric
drill wearing a piece of Nelson's
clothing he then threatens to harm
himself until Nelson confesses his
crimes however the bully is prepared and
he has brought weed juice from the
cemetery as Kelly starts drilling Nelson
sprays the weed juice on him stopping
his progress for a moment Adler pleads
with Kelly to stop but he drills his
knees hurting Nelson until he confesses
right then Dominique arrives convincing
Kelly to Halt the action amidst the
chaos Gus steals his gun from Adler and
in a fit of rage shoots Kelly to his bad
luck he and Nelson get shot in return
and the two die on the ground Darwin's
got his work cut out for him after after
the incident Dominique convinces Kelly
to give up his powers and return to
normal Adler also decides to help Kelly
and takes them and red elk to fluger's
cemetery where a ritual is performed
they dig the ancient grave and red elk
mentions that Kelly needs to die to
release the powers hearing this Kelly
attempts to flee but a police officer
shoots him accidentally shooting
Dominique and himself as well mortally
wounded Kelly kisses Dominique before
she passes away he then consumes the
dead fluger's heart to end his power
after this Adler shoots Kelly and kills
him in the last scene police officers
carry Dominique and Kelly's dead bodies
in a van suddenly on the way Dominique
wakes up revealing that she has now
possessed Kelly's healing power
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching